o meu nome é luiza eu sou pesquisadora
de iniciação científica do pago um
núcleo de estudos de gênero da unicamp
que fica line fish e hoje eu vou
apresentar pra vocês uma parte de uma
pesquisa desenvolvida sob orientação da
professora belelli cujo título é em
busca do príncipe discursos afetivo
sexuais e representações de gênero no
culto das princesas
bom pra quem não conhece o que é cultura
financeiros o custo das princesas a uma
campanha missionária evangélica de
aconselhamento sentimental a mulher a
mulher evangélica solteiras que estão em
busca do seu principal parceiro amoroso
de aulas quer encontrar o amor é o curso
ele transmitir ensinamentos sobre amor
sexo regras de comportamento regras de
moralidade enfim é mais porque o parto
dos estudos de gênero dos filmes de
gênero pra esse objeto de pesquisa e
quais são os meus objetivos aí
primeiramente estou tentando entender
como esses conselhos amorosos estão
performando e construindo modelos de
gênero modelos de feminilidade
masculinidade de analisados né e que irá
que estão implicados aí
em segundo lugar eu me questiono também
conta o conceito de amor romântico que o
discurso do culto pretende resgatar é em
terceiro lugar
é eu tento entender essa retomada de
certos valores morais como a pureza ea
castidade que aparecem como o conselho
sentais né pra pedagogia amorosa
culturas princesas na nossa sociedade
que vem passando nas últimas décadas por
tantas mudanças como por exemplo o
movimento feminista o advento da pílula
que tornaram o exercício sexual mais
livre e fizeram com que a virgindade
casamento perdesse sua importância moral
bom
quais os objetivos então eu me volta
para o campo a partir de duas frentes
principais a primeira dela internet é
parte da china o perfil online
acompanhando sobretudo nas redes sociais
tanto as postagens das páginas oficiais
do culto como a interação dos seguidores
com essas páginas né
em segundo lugar que a gente chama de
antropologia de observação participante
tradicional
eu tenho acompanhado os cultos e
conferências relacionadas à cultura as
princesas
eu tenho analisado também a cobertura da
mídia a respeito porque a sagatiba que
fundou com outras princesas em 2001
fundado pelo pastor essa chuva era o
personagem ela teve uma carreira
artística enfim é um personagem pouco
conhecido da mídia então são freqüentes
cobertura sobre a pessoa dela em último
lugar eu tenho realizado também em
entrevistas com seguidores do culto não
é príncipes e princesas é de cachorro
rex a princesas um novo hábitos bom o
pilar fundamental de tucho a pedagogia
amorosa do culto das princesas é se você
quer trair um príncipe um homem ideal
perfeito com intenções sérias para um
relacionamento amoroso durador com
vistas ao casamento você precisa antes
de tudo ser uma princesa uma mulher que
mereça esse príncipe e isso implica a
reconfiguração da própria subjetividade
por parte das meninas é como se fosse um
curso onde elas vão abandonar um hábito
antigo que elas tinham que é porque eu
vou explicar mais um pouco pra vocês
agora o que acho hatch que a princesa ao
cachorro rech vai ser uma menina que
digamos assim nas palavras do culto das
princesas né
ela não escolheu se guardar ela não se
valoriza emocionalmente ela não tem
autoestima elevada ela acaba se deixando
levar pelas próprias emoções e portanto
ela não vai ser respeitada e levada com
seriedade pelos homens é o padrão que
vamos assim todo mundo conhece né se
você quer ser respeitada
se você for mulher então você tem que
respeitar também não saiu mais ou menos
por aí
já a princesa é oposto princesa uma
menina que tem autoestima elas entrada
ela tem é claro é a relação com deus é
bastante importante porque está falando
de um culto religioso né
ela escolhe esperar em deus e se guarda
para o homem certo então tanto e isso e
se guardar não é só corporal sexualmente
mas também emocionalmente e aí eu quero
frisar agora contrapondo modelos de
feminilidade porque a gente pode pensar
que a cachorra hatch ela seria então o
equivalente a figura que a gente já
conhece da p
acho que é uma representação popular
bastante difundida sobre a sexualidade
feminina
no entanto a partir da minha observação
eu acabo concluindo que nós não são
exatamente a mesma coisa porque a
piriguete vai ser a mulher fizesse a
sexualidade de forma mais livre e por
isso mesmo é vista como uma mulher
perigosa por vestir enfim ela coloca em
xeque a nossa ordem social vamos dizer
assim
já a cachorro rex eu acredito que tenha
um componente mais emocional para
caracterização então não é
necessariamente a menina que não tem um
comportamento não monogâmico ou que
enfim é explicita culturalmente a sua
sexualidade não o cachorro rex ela é a
menina que não tem inteligência
emocional suficiente para conseguir um
relacionamento sério que implica tudo
isso que eu falei de se guardar
castidade pureza o comportamento
no entanto ela quer ter esse
relacionamento sério ela quer ser
princesa e ela quer um princípio mas ela
não consegue e já princesa seria um
pouco diferente da amélia né porque a
princesa também não é um personagem
completamente submisso ao namorado ela
pelo contrário no namoro ela vai mandar
namorado então ela tem uma posição
hierárquica um pouco diferente da da
representação da amélia vai caber a
princesa estabelece as regras do
casamento vai caber a princesa
estabelecer os limites de uma namorada
só que isso também é uma faca de dois
gumes né porque a gente pode dizer que
ela ocupa uma posição de mando
ela também ocupou posições de
responsabilidade com a gente vai ver
agora a castidade ocupa uma função
central para a construção do amor e isso
está diretamente ligada à princesa
alguma coisa de errada responsabilidade
também é dela por exemplo que vocês
podem ver um tweet da ativa que ser
virgem é o máximo é que acontece e vamos
diferenciar amor e prazer
isso é fundamental para a construção do
relacionamento segundo esse discurso
claro né é sempre bom frisar isso o amor
é um sentimento construído a longo prazo
por meio de conflitos que através dos
conflitos um casal se conhecer
verdadeiramente saber se aquela pessoa é
ou não boa para mim
o prazer é uma coisa instantânea e
momentânea fugaz tal que vem óbvio do
sexo do contato da intimidade física que
deve ser evitado porque ela deve ser
evitado porque o prazer acaba tendo ano
os conflitos que levariam o conhecimento
mútuo do casal então prazer e se ele for
antes da hora ou seja fora do casamento
ele impede a construção do amor pra isso
tudo a princesa é fundamental porque a
princesa fundamental porque esse
discurso ele naturaliza às diferenças
sexuais entre homens e mulheres que na
verdade são sociais nas construções
sociais
mas ele vai justificar biologicamente e
vai dizer que homens e mulheres
eles possuem naturalmente diferenças por
exemplo desejo sexual feminino ele é
dado apenas de forma intelectual
então a mulher se sente atraída pelo
homem que ela admira que passa também
pela figura bastante recorrente
popularmente do homem provedor né
já o homem ele vai se interessar pela
aparência física das mulheres
logo o desejo sexual feminino é mais
fácil de ser contínuo
ele é mais forte então a princesa ela
tem que conter os impulsos dela e ao
mesmo tempo conter os impulsos do
namorado ela se responsabiliza pelos
dois e assim ela se responsabiliza por
toda a gênese da relação e do amor
ela deve ser forte por si e pelo
parceiro
essa gestão da relação que cabe
sobretudo a princesa é também uma gestão
desse mesmo que ela deve empreender
então por exemplo as regras de
comportamento e de conduta vão recair
sobre tudo nela e não uma figura do
namorado por exemplo a princesa que não
pode usar uma saia curta para não tentar
o namorado
só que essa administração do
comportamento não é apenas interior
ela é sobretudo uma administração
emocional então a princesa ela precisa
conter as próprias expectativas saber
quando ela pode se apaixonar quando ela
não pode ela tem que por exemplo saber
superar as dores do passado saber
perdoar é e acima de tudo ela tem que
ter amor próprio amor próprio a virtude
pilar assim de todo esse discurso
só que ele não é um fim em si mesmo como
o próprio alf utilitário porque
apresenta precisa se amar pra que alguém
possa
a mala isso tudo eu tento interpretar na
chave do capitalismo efetivo que o
conceito cunhado pela socióloga revelou
que ela vai dizer que nesse momento
atual do capitalismo desde os anos 60 é
principalmente nós estamos imersos em
uma cultura terapêutica uma cultura da
gestão das emoções que a partir do
feminismo e da psicanálise na na segunda
metade do século passado
o sentimento começaram adquire maior
importância na esfera empresarial
privada no mercado de trabalho por
exemplo pra você ser um bom líder
você tem que saber gerir as emoções do
seu ambiente de trabalho saber gerir as
pessoas têm um bom relacionamento e
ainda tem uma vida afetiva pessoal
saudável né
mas ao mesmo tempo técnicas de gestão
empresarial baseadas na lógica dos meios
enfim passaram a integrar a nossa vida
afetiva então a administração dos nossos
sentimentos e relacionamentos
a gente entrega essas táticas como por
exemplo eu preciso me amar para que
alguém me ama como por exemplo eu não
posso criar expectativas
eu não posso demonstrar meu amor antes
da hora ainda que o impulso
sentimentalmente o que eu devo fazer
isso e é claro que eu tomando os
sentimentos não como uma coisa
psicológica ou só individual mas também
como construções sociais porque a forma
como a gente ama
segundo a autora também ela é dada por
roteiros românticos que seguiria uma
lógica social por exemplo a gente
aprende a amar através do que a gente vê
no cinema na televisão e na publicidade
ou na religião
enfim agora vou apresentar a pesquisa
ela tem mais ou menos oito meses em
andamento e agora um caminho que eu
gostaria de seguir daqui pra frente
porque até então eu tenho ficado mais no
discurso oficial do culto
eu acho que daqui para frente seria mais
interessante tentar ver como sujeito
príncipes e princesas lidam com todo
esse discurso na prática se a gente
pensar num contexto em que a gente tem
vários discursos morais sendo disputados
na nossa sociedade
a religião ela não é mais a produtora de
mônica de discursos morais
então ao mesmo tempo eu vou na igreja na
igreja
me dizem você precisa ser virgem até o
casamento mas se eu ligar se eu sou uma
adolescente eu liguei a televisão na
malhação está mostrando que não precisa
ser virgem
então a gente tem vários discursos
morais em conflitos e o que eu quero
tentar entender como as pessoas lidam
com isso nas suas práticas efetivas
enfim mas algumas coisas que eu já
observei netão apontando na direção de
uma posição de subalternidade da mulher
nesse discurso do culto das princesas e
aqui eu vou linkado eu vou elencar dois
exemplos principais para vocês primeiro
papel passivo que a mulher ocupa no flat
ela não pode tomar a iniciativa
a iniciativa tem que ser tomada
necessariamente pelo homem porque a
princesa é aquela que é cortejada ela se
valoriza tanto que ela não vai tomar a
iniciativa de procurar o se declarar
para alguém
em segundo lugar há o papel de mando que
a mulher ocupa durante o namoro depois
do casamento ele vai ter que se
converteu no papel de subalternidade
porque a gente vai ter uma estrutura de
família monogâmica tradicional onde o
homem vai ser o cabeça ea mulher vai ter
que digamos assim obedecê-lo né
mas depois do casamento é livre pra
expressar o desejo sexual em finalmente
e sobretudo assim a minha conclusão
maior até agora é contra a
marginalização né primeiro você e
hierarquizar você cria era que os dois
modelos de feminilidade
mas acima de tudo você imagina alisam
deles naquela da cachorra rege que é o
da mulher que vai expressar livremente
suas emoções segunda posição da princesa
que a mulher mais racional digamos assim
aí gente queria agradecer vocês pela
apresentação eu sei que muita gente aqui
nunca tinha ouvido falar
é um objectivo bastante diferente da de
vocês mas é muito legal aqui
apresentando e é muito legal que a gente
possa sair daqui hoje pensar nessas
questões muito obrigada meu e mail aqui
também caso alguém tem alguma dúvida
ligar e é isso